So let's talk about some
differences in perspective.
Developers write code.
They are responsible for
implementing feature requests,
fixing bugs, and so on.
Their incentives tend to
be more feature oriented.
They want to have big
launches as accomplishments.
Building new features might be dependent
on exploring new technologies or
approaches that have
not been used before.
Taking new risks.
Operations people run services.
They might take care of
physical servers, or
run services on hosted infrastructure.
They do deployment upkeep and
trouble shooting.
Their incentives tend to
be more stability oriented.
Anything that requires new untested
technologies or introduces new features
is a potential problem for the stability
and performance of the system.
The work Ops does is also usually
invisible to the company.
Ops is noticed when something does not
work, not when everything works fine.
The new release that developers get
praise for might cause problems in
production, and it's Ops that gets paged
if the app is unavailable to the user.
While both of these
perspectives are valid,
sometimes they seem like opposite
in conflicting interests.
Dev can feel like ops is blocking their
work by not providing resources fast
enough or not being supportive
of new cutting edge tech.
And Ops can feel like Devs are being
irresponsible and reckless and
just implement new features without
thinking about performance and security.
And there are other players in the
field, as well, like product management.
Product managers may be even
more feature oriented than devs.
They may make external promises, and
they might not ever talk with
traditional operations staff.
If the organization has a security team,
they may be even more change-overse than
ops, in the fear of introducing new,
unknown vulnerabilities.
Or, on the other hand, they may be more
willing to risk service down-time,
in order to patch nearly discovered
vulnerabilities quickly.
And then there's business management,
responsible for budgeting and
buying resources.
Ops may have to requisition
additional resources from them and
reason why they need those resources,
even if the underlying problem might
be performance of the new release.
So how can you get all of these involve
parties to understand each other's
different perspective and
work toward shared goals.
After all, the server that's offline
doesn't have any features and
that's bad for everybody.